que se diferencia el procedimiento de
suicidio asistido de la eutanasia y
porque para ustedes debía cambiar la
regulación
la única diferencia que existe entre la
eutanasia y el suicidio médicamente
asistido es quien lleva a cabo el
procedimiento quien causa la muerte en
colombia desde el año 97 es
completamente legal la eutanasia cuando
un médico causa directamente la muerte
pero era penalizada castigada por el
código penal cualquier otra ayuda
asistencia que llevarán a cabo los
profesiones de la medicina por eso desde
demandamos la constitucionalidad del
artículo 107 del código penal y la corte
constitucional lo que hace es legalizar
y es penalizar lo y por tanto incorporar
el suicidio médicamente asistido dentro
del derecho fundamental a morir
dignamente bueno hablemos entonces de
esos casos en los que ustedes dicen que
debe ser legal este suicidio asistido y
cómo afecta esto a pacientes y a los
prestadores de servicios
las personas que quieran solicitar el
suicidio médicamente asistido de manera
completamente legal y gratuita en
colombia deben cumplir con tres
requisitos los mismos requisitos de la
eutanasia lo que la corte ha hecho es
asimilar los y aplicarlos analógicamente
cuáles son primero tener una enfermedad
grave e incurable que ha sido
debidamente diagnosticado que esa
enfermedad cause unos dolores físicos o
un sufrimiento psicológico que haga que
la persona considere que su vida ha
dejado de ser digna y en tercer lugar
manifestar el consentimiento de manera
completa libre inequívoca y reiterada
cuando se cumplen esos requisitos las
ciudadanos colombianos y colombianas
pueden acudir al sistema de salud a
solicitar el procedimiento bueno esto es
en la teoría pero como en el caso de la
eutanasia este esto genera mucha
polémica en un país como colombia
después de esta decisión usted cree que
será fácil la implementación y el acceso
al suicidio asistido
en colombia cada vez más avanzamos en la
remoción de las barreras y de las
dificultades que enfrentan las personas
según el último registro
257 personas desde el 2015 y hasta el
2022 han accedido a una muerte
médicamente asistida por supuesto hay
barreras por supuesto hay dificultades
pero cada vez más las personas conocen
sus derechos y están dispuestos a
exigirlos ante el sistema de salud y
ante el sistema judicial vendremos venir
los primeros casos y seguramente las
primeras barreras pero tenemos todo para
resolver